that's right so spoiler talk for x-men
Days of Future past this spoiler talk
thing that I do I do because I enjoy
talking about spoilers if it's a movie I
really dug or I feel you know needs to
have spoilers talked about x-men Days of
Future past had so much going on in
it even if I didn't enjoy talking about
the spoilers I'd be like I gotta do some
spoiler talk that is an official spoiler
warning if you have not seen x-men Days
of Future past yet it's a spoiler
warning you've been warned so let's do
this so x-men Days of Future Passed
starts out at the very beginning it's
showing this world that reminds me
straight up of Terminator the Sentinels
target mutants because of like uh your
DNA you have the genetic code of
mutation alright well boom you're out
then they adapted to be able to tell if
people had the genetic code to pass on
mutation to their kids yeah it's not
like that person was a mitten or
anything but they would make a mutant so
cow dead which does that mean that
future is just full of women you
remember in x-men 2 pyro said they found
out the men are the ones that pass on
the genetic code to their kids so
actually it's his fault remember that
does that mean the signals just wipeout
dudes in the future is this the utopic
Society of Amazonian women what is the
pole the hole ratio and this apocalyptic
hole everyone lives in so Wolverine
goes back to his younger body cuz he's
the only one who can handle it cuz he
can heal faster than Kitty Pryde is
gonna like rip his consciousness apart
and so he goes back to the 70s
that's right that's before the Weapon X
program that can only mean one thing
Oh claws yeah I don't like them I never
have and never will give me metal closet
just have Logan wield the samurai sword
and kick ass uncle I did you make sense
I mean with the blades when they come
out they look like blades and then bum
claws are all round and chunky and weird
like bones so why aren't the metal
blades round and chunky and weird but
metal what he seems to go find Charles
Xavier and he told Xavier in the future
it's like well young you can just read
my mind you'll know I'm telling the
truth and Xavier was like I didn't have
my powers in 1973 I was like what what
are you talking about get your powers in
the 60s you don't have him in the 70s
it's weird what some when Logan comes up
on the mansion you see Hank McCoy and
he's not basically looking either so I
was confused but I like that I like it
when a movie throws me curveballs like
you don't know what's happening don't
worry we'll explain it to you slow folk
yeah you don't know it's a mystery it's
fun because that's how movies are
awesome and then Charles Xavier you see
him and not only does he not have his
powers but he's walking around because
there's this serum that can make him
walk but it takes away his powers
ultimately Charles Xavier
kind of a junkie even Hank McCoy's like
he takes too much of that stuff it's
really sad you seem like just tying it
off you know just doing that which
it was a good way to nerf Xavier if
Xavier had his powers the whole thing
would be over in like two seconds he
even tells Logan he's like you know what
I do remember you I think we approached
you a few years ago and I'm gonna tell
you what you told me off I didn't
want to be that guy but I was thinking
of my head I'm actually Charles Xavier
the phrase he told you was go
yourself not off most powerful mind
in the world just misquoted Wolverine
even fell for Xavier when he tried to
use cerebro and it just didn't work for
him it was like it's his brain it's like
a muscle that you have to exercise and
he's been out of practice for so long
he's weak just mentally he's weak he's
not the guy he used to be he's not the
guy he's gonna be so it's frustrating
for him but it's okay because Wolverines
like read my mind because my mind is
still linked to my body in the future
you know like avatar style and so
young Xavier talks to old Xavier oh man
that was just meant to happen they
shouldn't have shown that in the trailer
because the first time I saw that was in
this movie when I saw the movie I'd be
like good ultimately they need to find
Raven they need to find a mystique
because what happened was mystique kills
traps and she gets captured in the fact
that Trask was martyred because a mutant
killed him that was bad enough but her
DNA allowed the government to make
sentinels that would adapt to any Mutant
power that's how they had the super
sentinels to have in the future so we
got to stop all that from happening
and to do it they need the help of one
man magneto but to get him they need the
help of one other man and that's a guy
didn't tell you about in my review I
wanted to talk about him but I wanted
you guys to go into the movie not
hearing me say I wanted you to find out
yourselves like I did that Quicksilver
is awesome seriously I love that dude
he's super fast he's kind of crazy and
quirky I did he was an interesting
character and a really interesting movie
but they need his help to break magneto
out of the Pentagon you probably need
someone who's super fast and he gets him
out at first you know Charles Xavier
punches magneto in the face it's like
you're a dick and then all these guys
whip out their guns sing Quicksilver
doesn't say all these guys just unload
on him and Quicksilver stop well he
doesn't stop time he speeds up he's puts
on his headphones and runs on the wall
which I love I love the fact that you
can see the physics of someone who is
super fast but his speed he does normal
speed so he's running on the wall he
just goes by a guy him on the face just
sweet because to that guy it's just a
super-fast app took a punch he's thrown
place that dudes wish did that velocity
the plate would probably take the guy's
head off he takes another guy's
armies like ant like that so the guy's
just gonna deck himself moves all the
bullets out of the way and then he just
goes back to normal time you see the
room clear just everything just happens
I was like that dudes a badass and then
after that they do the most logical
thing possible
they just say goodbye to that guy and
let Quicksilver go I just feel like
someone who is super fast like that you
want to keep him around
but either let him go I did like that
one line where Quicksilver looks at
magneto and he's like you can move metal
my mom knew a guy you could do that I
was like boom is nice Magneto's kid kind
of maybe but not but has a good Easter
Egg if you have a sister and I love the
fact that they show that magneto will do
whatever he needs to do for his cause
even if that means killing mystique
killing Raven he's puts a gun to he's
like sorry I gotta save the future and
then beast tackles him doesn't matter
the gun pops out of Magneto's hammies
all boom boom
cuz he's magneto and that showed me
I'm like he's not conflicted he's not
should I be good should I not that's
mystique in this movie mistakes the
conflicted one Erik Lehnsherr is magneto
in this movie straight up then they get
Mystique's blood anyway because the
bullet nails are in the leg and so
they're gonna create the super sentinels
anyway only difference is Trask is alive
and I love what Hank McCoy says about
that he's like in time there's a theory
that it's just you can't change it it's
constant and it is destiny the speech
straight up reminded me of legacy it
came because legacy Kane's about you
trying to alter destiny and time and
things that are constant and you can't
change it but Raziel might be able to
and Kane tells him use like drop us down
into a russian river the current simply
courses around and flows on as if the
obstruction were never there and you
start to see it you're like you looks
pretty fatalistic this is looking grim
I'm starting to doubt your mission I'm
thinking the future cannot be saved but
of course we can't leave it off like
that because if they don't change the
future we can't have our apocalypse
movie in the end Magneto's like you know
what now's the time I'm going to waste
the president so to kill tricky dicky he
picks up a stadium remember a few years
ago when Xavier was like move that
satellite dish use like it's hard rage
and serenity
he's like our agent serenity the
submarine this one is like a huge
Stadium no problem katana which makes
Magneto pretty badass but in the end
mystique did turn good mystique saved
the president and so they're like oh
well not all mutants are bad and vol
Trask is kind of a let's shut
down his thing The Sentinel started
firing out people anyway they're
probably defective so when we get to the
future you see the features all
holy Wolverine's back in the
mansion you walks downstairs and you see
jean grey and he's like Jean did you see
Scott summer I was really happy to see
cycle why was I happy to see Cyclops
it's such a boy Scott but when I saw him
I felt like Wolverine did he's like
Scott good to see it you can tell this
movie was Bryan Singer's way being like
that screw it you know what we're gonna
undo some of the shitty however you
find out Bryan Singer did not
discriminate in order to undo all the
stuff that we didn't like about the past
x-men movies you have to undo the stuff
that you did like it shows what happened
Wolverine got out of the water you know
because magneto tried to drown him and
then Stryker was like I'll take him from
here and he turns around you see the
eyes because he's mystique so Stryker
never got Wolverine so bone claws Jeremy
well it's implied he didn't get him
maybe the Weapon X program maybe it did
happen but what I assess is everything
that was x-men 1x 2x men United X 3 the
last whatever piece of x-men
origins Wolverine and even the Wolverine
all of that did not happen its x-men
first class and x-men Days of Future
past now which is really ballsy a lot of
directors would just try to undo the
other guys stuff Bryan Singer was like
alright I'll create a new timeline and
even undo the movies that I did the only
way to put it back on course and I
actually thought that was pretty gutsy
on everyone's part even the studio's
they were like we made the Wolverine
less than a year ago and now it's just
undone it didn't happen but most is less
than 365 days old and it's now nothing I
mean the x-men movies have been taken on
by a few different directors it was like
Xavier and x-men 3 he was friends with
magneto and he was walking in the 80s
then in x-men first class he was
paralyzed and now he's not friends with
magneto in the 60 so did x-men 3 happen
well in this movie it shows flashbacks
of x-men 3 and Jean was dead because
obviously Wolverines like Oh Jean you're
alive so x-men 3 did happen it doesn't
even explain how Xavier is alive at the
end of the Wolverine you know that
post-credit scene that showed it's like
oh we need your help Wolverine and
Xavier is alive he just it doesn't
explain how he's alive and in the
Wolverine Wolverine had bone claws at
the end of that movie cuz silver samurai
sliced off the metal the adamantium bone
claws grew back the adamantium doesn't
what in the future in this movie
Green has metal clubs did you can tell
everyone was like screw it there's no
continuity because a few different
directors have taken on these projects
and they screwed everything up so here
you go first class and Days of Future
past done but in the post credit scene
you see it you see it's just the back of
some guy in ancient Egypt with his hands
up all like this and everyone's
going and summer noon you're like okay
don't you see his grey skin you're like
apocalypse is gonna kill everything that
was apocalypse in the end credits scene
in Apocalypse is bad news he's called
apocalypse even has the four horsemen
the Bible wrote about the guy he's bad
and now he's coming I love this movie
it's great it's one of the best movies
I've seen this year this movie it is
everything I wanted in a summer
blockbuster fun action movie and it was
a good look it was a good movie actually
curious about this everyone had a crush
on one of the ex people at one point in
their life me Psylocke done it's just
it's done
what is your ex person whoever they are
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you